yeah you know when to welcome to zero
playing I am Sherlock Sherlock
khaleesies nikolaos okay let's go for a
nympho 96 lime soda coring quite well
with that so smaller big incentive to
change hmm yeah can think of the night
regrouping I think I'll do that
uh-huh so it tries to play before or
what's the deal I can do this 494 v4
loses a piece o hmm not quite clear to
me what the plan was maybe you just
blundered this movie after coming 94 I'm
attacking beat three twice and it too so
it should lose some material okay so not
to do one so but i can go here now right
take and take be 3 or this one i can
take this also doesn't do much though
but i can take here this is certainly
good and take the tool next just take
the tool we cannot take with the rookie
has to take with a queen hmm i wonder if
i have something better you probably not
but it is pretty good and now i have a
fantastic night if i go III you will
take with the Queen Queen takes f takes
it's a very nice ending but i also just
have bishop at five which is which is
pretty good or age six cents the night
back many good lines
okay let's do this super simple method
and then work 2-8 being a pawn up and
having a nice smile appears on c5 sorry
for the sound fit need to close that
bottle here always I was always a danger
last couple of moments to to knock it
over so want to make sure that it
doesn't spill all over my desk so what
is he doing now why it's got very little
and now I'm going in three right three
eggs
it still has F for their route 22 22
takes checks this one yeah that wins
okay yeah okay the yes this is this one
shuttle here and also having a nice
structure the only thing is Bishop t5
admittedly which is kind of annoying
andrew get five potentially huh maybe I
shouldn't have played it like that
slightly annoying rookie for maybe this
is a good move threatening on h4 should
be five though hmm yeah Bishop t5
it's pretty bad pretty bad technical
play this one maybe yeah for up to two
or queen detune i can google f3 or that
one
I'm chin such a [ __ ] what did i do here
from a completely winning position know
this stuff and I have to solve problems
him I shouldn't have played III hi
Barney I really shouldn't have done that
it already felt a little bit wrong and
could have just played any other move
and he's got absolutely nothing and you
know I said I have to fight here I
assure no Bishop before it doesn't work
amazing and it was also entirely
unnecessary
position sue might be quite good but I'm
going 40-something seconds and it could
have been so much easier Bishop f 3 35
and not a clean win least I don't see it
why did I do that and so we had moved
anyway at least I got queen strain it
and maybe it wasn't so bad this position
is at least somewhat easier to play how
callous you cannot avoid avoid the conch
right here and strange check check
check check check check check so it is
winning but still 20-somethings change
okay check this looks doable check
that's a maid net meeting that night
resides Wow our stuff yeah and also
totally unnecessary after that check
excellent physician out of the opening
yeah here we should be to simply ignored
reform after which blacks position is
excellent and oops yeah I think this is
a good way of playing h6 keeping it very
simple you know this when this fortifies
tonight which is now completely safe and
this Bishop is not doing anything I got
very tempted by this by this you three
move computer actually think it's
objectively the best but still I think
from a human perspective I just play
routine moves and keep the position as
is and this Bishop never does anything
and I will win any endgame very easily
and here's somehow yeah the computer
gives route before but I could I saw
this move with this idea but I wasn't
sure if this is so clear I saw that but
I cannot defend our seven now the engine
however is very cool just is this check
and sense i'm winning now okay I'm
possible this isn't black wins yeah okay
that's the engine I didn't
see the full full line and after not
seeing this I mean some some issues em
okay the night went over here and now I
think I probably kind of okay and five
this yeah this is now debatable for sure
this is a good idea I cook you don't
want to take on b6 that's cool just
taking this rather unimportant looking
porn instead this is better for black so
probably it has to take care check this
and there's nothing here I amazing this
is jess check check and the engine gives
000 we had this also this him amazing ed
I've got the better ending which are
managed to win in 30 something second
switch check I'm happy about check check
check yeah and now he gave me a check
horns which was very nice tough game I
still think I shouldn't have played you
three that made life a bit more
difficult there then it needed to be for
human player with little time okay
thanks for watching